mais ces pubs sexy j'en ai marre là bas
quoi tu préfère faire la liste
évidemment non mais c'est pas la
question on attend les à
l'électroménager ça a révolutionné notre
vie la nouvelle fois qu'un temps tu es
vraiment en train de défendre le sexisme
la hâte en laisse moi aller jusqu'au
bout c'est bon je vais prendre les dires
un pad roubaix attend patrick chouchou
tubert et nous chercher des bières s'te
plaît merci petit cul alors oui
l'électroménager aujourd'hui on associe
plutôt ça un symbole d'asservissement de
la femme tout simplement parce que c'est
encore elle qui majoritairement assurent
les tâches ménagères
mais justement c'est bien parce que
traditionnellement les tâches ménagères
lui reviennent que l'électroménager a
révolutionné sacre et pour comprendre il
faut déjà savoir ce que c'est que le
quotidien d'une femme
avant ces avancées technologiques et
c'est aussi l'occasion de se demander
pourquoi c'est elle qui est en charge de
s'occuper du foyer normalement c'est
l'instinct maternel
les femmes elles sont plus on slaoui
loto thé pas sensible a été petit break
je peux apporter un bébé si tu vas
t'occuper du foyer va aller ça va je te
connais oui je te connais où il est
clair aussi dit ça je t'ai connu dans le
disait pas ça bon alors déjà il faut
savoir que cette répartition des tâches
homme femme dans la famille elle est
relativement récente elle date du 19e
siècle ou du moins c'est la période où
elle s'est vraiment instaurée et oui
parce qu avant l'industrialisation la
grande majorité des gens travaillent là
où ils vivent
la majorité de la production est
réalisée dans le cadre domestique est
l'exemple le plus parlant basse et la
ferme
tout le monde travaille à la ferme pas
que monsieur et on a tout sur place mais
la révolution industrielle dissocie les
espace de vie puisque avec les usines ce
n'est plus le travailleur qui est
propriétaire des moyens de production
donc il faut sortir de la maison pour
bosser le rôle masculin devient alors
celui du gagne-pain et surtout du
travail rémunéré à l'extérieur mais bien
sûr quand on est super pauvres les
femmes aussi vous travaillé à l'usiné
mais l'image de l'ouvrière est confronté
à une autre celle de la femme bourgeoise
qui peut rester à la maison parce que
monsieur rapporte assez on a alors la
promotion d'un nouveau schéma familial
qui cristallise la division des rôles
sexués des hommes et des femmes et qui
est renforcée par une conception
fondamentaliste de la famille qui se
base sur la complémentarité des sexes et
que l'on justifie comme relevant de
l'ordre naturel des choses
selon la tradition justement à cette
époque là on a la médecine qui se
développent et notamment l'anthropologie
et on va commencer à distinguer le corps
de l'homme du corps de la femme est en
france on a la grande chance d'avoir
paul broca qui au 19e siècle va fonder
la société d'anthropologie de paris
on remarque que ya des femmes avec un
crâne plus petit et des hommes avec un
crâne plus gros et comme bas on sait
tous que la femme elle est moins
intelligente que l'homme en séance voilà
on s'est tous forcément on peut pas
négliger le fait que avoir un cerveau
plus petit c'est être moins intelligente
mais ce qui est marrant c'est que cette
distinction là elle va être encouragé
chez
des ombres dans la bourgeoisie elle va
être mise en valeur dans les codes les
femmes c'est bien qu'elle soit féminine
est pas fait pour ça et donc les femmes
qui sont à la ferme bombard va admettre
qu'elles ont pas le même type de
squelettes voilà alors du coup les
femmes qui sont à la ferme on considère
qu'elles ont pas le même succès que les
femmes qui sont dans la prochaine bah
disons qu'on va surtout étudié des
femmes qui sont dans la bourgeoisie et
dire balas et bien voilà mais du coup ce
qui est marrant c'est que c'est vraiment
l'anatomie du 19e siècle qui va définir
ces différences qui va ancrer dans la
science les différences entre les hommes
et les femmes voilà donc et ba ont
rejoint ce que je disais il ya une une
construction sociale avec des valeurs
qui qui est appuyée par la science et du
coup c'est pour ça qu'on en arrive à ce
gros clichés de c'est la femme qui doit
faire ceci cela et les tâches ménagères
alors certes le rôle des femmes comme
pourvoyeuse de soins qui s'occupe des
enfants stade d'avant mais c'est juste
que ça se cristallisent particulièrement
à ce moment là avec l'émergence de la
classe bourgeoise donc les nouveaux
riches mais roturier qui peuvent se
permettre une vie de nobles qui peuvent
se permettre que seulement 1 seulement
de la famille travaillent et qui
contrairement aux nobles valorise le
travail car c'est ce qui leur a permis
l'enrichissement le travail mais que de
monsieur donc bref mais cette
répartition hommes-femmes des tâches
c'est quelque chose qui est
progressivement remis en cause du xxème
siècle jusqu'à nos jours mais du coup
avant le quotidien des femmes
en tout cas c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin de travailler à l'usiné c'est
d'être au foyer parce que la société a
dit que c'était ça le modèle de la bonne
femme
alors bon bah en ce qui concerne leur
quotidien je vous fais pas un dessin
assez loin ben voilà du coup pour passer
faire à manger et s'occupe legolas
passer le balai [ __ ] ta voix super
balèze s'échoue fais pas un dessin
donc c'est là qu'au xxème siècle le
temps que ça se démocratise un peu le
progrès technologique des boules et
changent peu à peu le quotidien des
femmes et des filles et plus largement
dans les années 1930 on a les premières
machines à laver donc plus de frottage
ni d'essorage à la main on a les
premières
r nous intéressons nous d'abord du bois
et les premiers réfrigérateurs qui
permettent de s'approvisionner en ruf -
ce point puisqu'on peut la conserver
plus longtemps
par ailleurs dès le 19ème siècle il se
développe ce qu'on appelle les arts
ménagers et les écoles pour femmes pour
apprendre à bien tenir leur foyer qui
sont parfois optimisé sur le modèle du
taylorisme alors encore une fois ça peut
paraître être un vecteur d'oppression et
un sens ça l'est mais c'est aussi la
possibilité pour les femmes d'optimiser
leur temps d'être plus rapide plus
efficace et donc pas d'avoir plus de
temps pour elle
ces écoles se multiplient après la
guerre on y apprend l'hygiène la
puériculture le jardinage la couture
tout pour bien tenir son foyer donc mais
aussi souvent les bases de la
comptabilité et de la sténographie ce
qui leur permet aussi et éventuellement
de travailler en dehors du foyer
bref les arts ménagers et
l'électroménager ce sont des trucs qui
ont profondément changé et faciliter la
vie des femmes
le problème évidemment daes excellent
qui était et qui sont toujours encore
beaucoup en charge de ces tâches et que
oui aujourd'hui les publicités genre et
en 2019
ça nous casse les ovaires par exemple on
a de plus en plus de pères au foyer
parce que aujourd'hui les femmes aussi
ont des carrières importante est
brillante et des voix dans certains
ménages
il est plus intéressant pour le couple
hétérosexuel de privilèges et la
carrière de la femme que celle de
l'homme
même si c'est pas encore très fréquents
ce qui est intéressant en revanche c'est
que les hommes au foyer ont besoin de
justifier leur présence à la maison
comme un travail à part entière c'est ce
qu'a montré la sociologue
myriam château la plupart des hommes
qu'elle a interrogés pour son enquête
justifie consciemment ou inconsciemment
leur présence à la maison en équivalence
dessous économisés par rapport aux faits
deux à payer la garde des enfants le
ménage pour le foyer le temps gagné etc
c'est logique parce que dans nos schémas
traditionnels toujours bien ancrée
malgré nos l'homme est le pourvoyeur de
ressources donc il convertit les
activités qui fait à la maison en
ressources alors que les femmes au foyer
ne considère pas tellement leur activité
comme un travail la journaliste mona
chollet a aussi souligné le paradoxe
dans lequel se retrouvent les femmes qui
restent à la maison à la fois idéalisé
par les schémas traditionnels et méprisé
car les tâches ménagères ne sont pas
perçues comme positives une solution dit
elle pourrait être la piste du salaire
ménagers c'est une revendication de
certains groupes féministes qui
permettraient de reconnaître que
s'occuper de la maison est un vrai
travail et ceci que l'on soit un homme
ou une femme
donc évidemment je discute pas de si
c'est faisable économiquement aux bafta
mon domaine de ce fait mais ce serait
intéressant car positifs aussi bien pour
les hommes au foyer qui ont besoin de
valoriser leurs tâches comme étant du
travail pour les accepter que pour les
femmes qui ne sont pas considérés dans
cette situation de même mais real
château propose le prolongement du congé
paternité son enquête sur les pères au
foyer montrent qu'une mesure de ce type
pour être efficace car il semble qu'une
plus grande disponibilité temporel
combinée à la présence d'enfants dans le
foyer augmente l'investissement du
parent dans les tâches domestiques et
cet investissement perdure même lorsque
le parent retourne travailler après son
compte
et puis la sociologue explique aussi
dans son article que visiblement il est
plus facile de changer les mentalités
par la législation que la législation
par les mentalités donc peut-être qu'il
faudrait que l'état prenne des
initiatives dans ce sens
just say the john booth et why élégante
qui parle c'est bon maintenant on l'a la
black beauty success mot illimité c'est
pour faire un truc dst les mecs ils font
un truc des meufs nanar déjà quand j'ai
proposé ils n'ont pas dit non tu fais
quoi tu vas pas contre avec cette écoute
je les répare est gelée bidouiller et
maintenant je pense que il est bon pour
plusieurs centaines d'années merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé ce qui est
clairement le meilleur épisode du vortex
on va pas se mentir
j'espère que vous avez aimé vous pouvez
laisser un petit commentaire pour nous
de dire un petit pouce en l'air
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et on peut
aussi se retrouver sur notre discorde et
nous on vous dit à dans une semaine
[Musique]